hello everyone this is woman's
grandmaster sabina feuscher
welcome back to san luis chess club's
youtube channel and welcome back
to uh my
lesson uh this video is going to be
focused on
games of the week um
games that i chose
for today will be
three we'll see how many of those will
have the chance to
to go over i hope all of them because i
found them
very interesting and i think there's so
much
we can learn from them um without
further ado
oops
i try to keep the the chat open but i'm
not sure if i'll be able to do so
because
uh i'm not sure if it will work
just a moment
maybe not maybe not
because then we will just you guys will
just hear me twice okay
let's get started
the first game that i chose for today
was played in the european um
club cup i believe it was
between grandmasters funny and
gatakomsky
gotta is is um
grandmaster and and friend
um i felt bad i had to choose one of
these games that he lost but i think it
this game has
quite a lot of interesting interesting
things to talk about
and and i hope it will be helpful um
for everyone so the game started as
follows d4
d5 c4 a6 knight f3
knight f6 knight bd2 this
line has become more popular against
the slav defense
of course more normal things to be
played here on knight c6
c3 or e3 for white this has become a
little bit popular
um and the idea is that okay you are
messing up
the development of your dark square
bishop but in the same time you are
um you have the knight
protecting each other and also you can
capture in c4
you're both from c3 and d2 you're
supporting the e4 pawn push so you're
not worried about that so much
most people play bishop f5 in this
position but in this specific game
gata decided to play g6
b3 bishop g7 bishop b2
castle and now white has to proceed with
their development as well so of course
e3 first
we start with e3 bishop e2 castle
everything
like very normal and then eventually
white is going to attack the center and
get
give themselves more space black is
trying to do something similar of course
uh in many d4 d5s black is struggling
with this bishop in c8 so wherever you
have the opportunity
whenever you have it to take it out you
should do so
the black played bishop g4
and e6 was gata's choice
kind of playing in in a miran style
um but now after the bishop is out which
it can be given for for the knight in f3
knight bd7 is a little bit uh is
very common as well and the idea for
black is of course to keep alive the
opportunity to attack the center at some
point with c5 or e5
this way you still have those
opportunities ready but
you kind of try to keep a more solid
position temporary
castle knight bd7 and
in this position um this it is kind of
normal for white to take advantage of
the fact that
uh black's bishop is in g4 um
and it's stuck there so you want to take
to have something right so you'll get
the bishop pair
by playing h3 you're forcing black to
capture here
bishop f5 is an option but and that
would be some g4
uh bishop e4 and then maybe knight e5
and
this bishop will be trapped somehow so
you're better off just taking
just to avoid issues and
um i think knight takes f3
could be normal but bishop takes f3 is
nice as well
with keeping again uh opportunities to
play e4 for white
and we're playing we're seeing
um now a position with a bishop there
i think the bishop pair is
very strong in a lot of uh situations
uh when the position is closed obviously
you may not be able to know
to to take advantage of it as much
but with this pawn structure e4 usually
helps
white very much and if there's a trade
then there'll be d5
a very typical idea for white as a plan
and black kinda has to stay a little bit
restricted
gotta play a5 here
queen c2 28
the idea of queen b8 is to free the
stroke
to be able to be brought on the side of
the board but it's also
potentially supporting some b5s
and also with the bishop being in g7 um
you also may want to have control over
these dark squares but
um this is kind of a cool typical idea
the position is really balanced you
cannot say that someone is much better
what i like
i liked about this game the reason i
chose it you will see is that
white has a lot of time for maneuvering
and if you are not able to find
some way of counter play it just seems
like why just step by step improves
this is the reason why i showed this
game i want you guys to pay attention to
the way
white improves each step each step of
the way so rook c1
and obviously are not we're putting the
rook here to maybe have the chance at
some point to take but
also we can consider c5 you're keeping
the tensions you're not in a rush to
make any trades
now white is playing a3 in case of a4
you always have b4
to get a little bit more space 98
and now e4 why 98 well
with black you need something to do and
i think e5 is certainly something you
have to play you just need to be
ready mentally to do it because in a way
you are opening up the center so you're
helping white's bishop there
but um
if you don't do it then you are
you're restricted 98 somehow can help
with that
because you're opening up your bishop
but
with 98 you're going away from the
control of the e4 square and now it is
white who gets to play e4
which is a move that i told you will be
part of white's plan anyways
kind of have to take or else you know
you may lose something there
knight takes e4 and now black is coming
back
to f6 to offer the trade now personally
once again i
do believe that move kind of i mean i
would
try to play it with black uh i would not
really want to play such
uh passive position unless i really
really have to i feel that this is
in a way necessary many people don't
like to push
e5 when they have a fiance picture
because
it is often perceived that white could
pass by you
and then your bishop will stay closed
but thankfully we'll have a five ideas
and then e4
and we'll get to trade that [ __ ] award
or or at least open it
and gather played bishop uh sorry knight
of six
and now because white has managed to
trade those pawns open up the position
a little bit they're going back for
knight g3 with the idea of
um avoiding tr more trades
because black is lacking space
98 back and now because e5 will be an
idea that black is considering
white is retreating or returning on the
e file to try to stop
that pawn push knight d6 rook
a2d1 now you've placed your pieces
with white on central files to control a
lot of the squares
a lot of the both of the pushes c5 and
e5
and um and let's see what happened next
all right queen e7
uh putting pressure on d4 of course and
now i
really really like what white chose to
do because d5 could be a move you want
to play
in order to open your bishop pair but
you're not rushing
because you have the control in the
center and black does not have a simple
way
to open it up it stays this solid all of
white's pieces are well placed
white can think of a way to open up a
new front
and he did so h4 with adh5
rook v8 h5
knight f6 [ __ ] t1
and this bishop is going to be brought
on this other side of the board
to help with the attack black needs to
do something
needs to attack something and this is
the only way they can do things but
we're not going to touch we're not going
to trade
white push t5 i like this move very much
knight back
and now he played bishop f4 now i feel
that maybe bishop g5 would have been a
slightly better approach or maybe even
h6 first
because you're keeping the knight pinned
and then maybe you have some options
to to bring your queen to f4 and somehow
put more pressure
but bishop f4 was chosen by white
and now we should be fine
this is not necessarily something that
white wants to do in my opinion to trade
the
the bishop fair but um
if you don't i mean he probably didn't
want to go bishop g5
and he's thinking if we get to trade
this bishop white is going to be able to
uh to continue try to bring pieces to
attack black's king
so that was basically the idea the queen
side is blockaded there is no way for
black to open up
any a5 a4 we can play b4 and b4
we can play a4 so that will be
the way things will go on that side of
the board
black has no way to try to open up the
position they just have to try to stay
and defend
so step by step white can improve after
the train
queen c1 so the queen could be brought
to the attack later on it wasn't
meant to be there yet queen d2 first and
now h6
pushing the bishop back and now it is
time
to make this decision
there are some holes in the position so
we're bringing our knight to a slightly
better location we'll see
on which one of those will go and black
has decided to play a fight now while
this may be a necessity
you have to remember that this pawn
unfortunately stays a backwards pawn is
going to be weak
you're opening up that indeed but that
pawn
could cause could be you know causing a
lot of damage in black's position
96 there's an outpost we're bringing our
knight to a slightly
better location if you ever take it
of course bishop takes that one will be
weak
g7 is weak too black would not want to
give up the bishop for the knight
so they chose to retreat and now we need
some kind of plan for white and i think
it would be nice
for white to try to double on the e pawn
but instead white
i mean sorry white did do that but not
think consider
black's counterplay did not consider
that black would actually have something
and this was a really nice idea that
black came up with queen e7 to bring the
queen to h4
try to get this h6 pawn we brought it
all the way there and
it doesn't seem like black can get it
but if there is a way for them to get it
uh black will not have such a bad
position after all because the bishop
will come back to g7 keep the king safe
and we won't be able to do so much and i
think this is a moment where white
should have like could have played a
little bit better maybe play g3 maybe go
bishop g3 anyways that bishop needed to
be moved from there
in order to put pressure on the e6 pawn
just making sure that black would not
have the opportunity to bring in the
queen to take the
uh h6 pawn instead
this move was played which allowed queen
h4 and now
it is impossible to stop the capture of
the h6 pawn
the only way white was able to do that
is by actually trading the bishop
and now black didn't take of course
because if you take group 6
that was the whole point but this knight
f4 intermediate
move might have been a move that white
missed
and uh protecting this pawn and now this
is weak
so we're going to have the opportunity
to take it rookie 3
and now um again we're not taking the
pawn just yet
because if you do there's this kind of
cute idea d5
and and they're trying to open this
and we're trying to have these checked
if you think like this
why can't we play g3 immediately
because of queen g5 so what's the
difference
this is the difference okay we have a
check knife
which we didn't have before so this is a
very beautiful pawn sacrifice
in order to free a square that we can
utilize for the attack
and this part of the game was played
well by both players i think
black to the exchange uh and now
played queen e7 to keep the e6 pawn
protected
now that with the exchange up
it's still not a big deal for black
because that 19 d6
is basically the killer the the
strongest piece ever you cannot
do anything about it i love this knife
here on the south pole you can't
the only way you get rid of it is by
sacrificing your exchange back
if you see a threat and now queen takes
g7 rook stakes there
and for some reason black
did not go for the capture of this pawn
maybe this was
the worrisome idea but you really need
to
be ready that you're not going to
to be able to take advantage of your
exchange you have to give the exchange
back
in this position and just you know
keep the safety of your king queen would
go to f6 maybe the rook would go f8 f7
try to trade and um and
and i think this position should be uh
despite the weak king black should be
able to hold without any problems i mean
it's
but it's not so difficult i mean
depending on the time that both players
had here
it's not so easy to make that decision i
think
maybe black thought that they had to
chance to stay a little bit longer
in this position and not um not
give back the exchange immediately and
so gata played rook a7
and that was a mistake after this move
white is able to simply
to simply destroy all of these
weaknesses that black has stayed with
um and like this is weak this is weak
uh and then if these pawns stay past
white can
simply march them and there will be
nothing that black will be able to do
and so after rook a7 forcing
the rook trains queen f8 queen takes c6
and now black does not quite have a way
to uh to take advantage of the situation
there's no way to coordinate the queen
and the rook to try to
uh to take over white's uh a king and
now
few checks after which
b6 black had one check
but now after b5 there's no way to stop
uh stop the response queen the eighth
final blunder but it really doesn't
matter
here anymore any other move
also wouldn't have helped
because white is threatening acting pawn
move the queen
push every three pawns and the night
there's no way
to do anything so i i again once again i
chose this game because i
felt that um it just showed a very
simple play by white step by step
improvement there is
a little bit of a mistake a little bit
of a moment where
black kind of managed to equalize
uh if that wasn't gonna you know happen
probably
you know this game would be even even
better but i just
feel that it was important to understand
how to play with uh
with the bishop pair how to have
patience how to step by step improve
your position
you have control over the center don't
necessarily
rush to to get
um to trade everything you want to try
to
create a play on the other side of the
board as well
and of course i like
i like the idea that sometimes we mess
up but
um but we come back
from from it we can still improve
uh we just need to have a little bit of
patience
that's with the with this game i hope
you guys liked it my next game
choice of game was played between
um run forest
uh and dudum von forsen
has had a great start of the uh year
winning uh vikanze
and uh i have been following him for
quite some time now we used to play in
the same
tournament like we played a few years in
the same tournament in france
and i would always see him so so um
passionate and determined to get better
and dude of course
another very strong
young chess player from poland who's
shown tremendous
like amazing games in the past uh few
years
so definitely i just i thought
okay there's no way i'm not going to
show this game and it also happens to be
uh sicilian and i know a lot of people
enjoy watching sicilian games
so and it's not a very long game either
more like a
nice attacking game so i thought i would
i would show it
it was a naidorf sicilian
e4 c5 knight f3 v6
before c takes d495d4 knight f69c3
and a6 um it's interesting because like
the
the the reason i kind of uh came across
this game i decided to show is
because here after a6 there are lots of
moves that that i can play like bishop
bishop e3 bishop g5 bishop e2 bishop c4
i don't know h3 so many moves but
there was um van forest chose this queen
d3 move which
it was kind of like more uh uh
not a novelty but it's it's a type of
move that usually don't make you don't
take your queen out
early in the game and i remembered okay
i have a fun memory of this move
because um in 2019 in the u.s women's
championship i play the game myself
i and i played
such an idea um in my game against irena
crush
um she actually i had white pieces
and she had black pieces and she played
knight c6
i won bishop g5 and here i play queen d3
and um it's it was a similar idea
and uh you know when i saw the game i
thought oh
similar idea let's see let's see how it
went for him but
unfortunately it didn't go as great as
it that game went for me
but i think it's certainly an
interesting idea to consider
um oftentimes people in the sicilian
or against the sicilian place the queen
in d2 in order to have you know
potential ideas you're on the dark
square but or
f3 i've seen it plays played often
for white as well but in d3 is
interesting because you protect e4
you're still keeping control the control
over the center and you also have the
ability
to bring it to e3 h3 depends
what black plays as well and um
yeah i thought it's it's kind of an
interesting choice
and i like black's approach of
continuing their development
his development of course knight bd7
bishop e2 e6 and now
you know black wants zombie five so i
decided to
to stop it by pushing a4 and this
position is pretty balanced
in b6 castle
bishop b7 and it seems that up to this
point
um everything went according to plan
other people have played
this previously but in this position
white went for somewhat of a novelty i
guess queen g3
the point is that you're keeping of
course those two pawns
under attack to make it difficult for
black to finish development but you're
moving in the queen
from the protection of the e4 pawn which
is
maybe not ideal bishop g5 has been tried
here
by ganesh now i got it i mean
he's it was a 2000 player
uh the point 2 2100 um
and the game was from 2008 there was
there was a game play like this which is
kind of interesting i think um
h6 and white took
root e1 bishop e7 and then y2k
continued with f4 and so on
and um yeah they had a pretty good
it it's kind of the typical plan for
white
but valforce came up with this
interesting idea of giving up this pawn
for the initiative and to take advantage
of black skin in the center and it's not
so easy for black
to bring the skin to safety and i think
that's what he thought
well it wasn't really like that it
didn't happen like that but that was
probably the
the whole idea that it's not going to be
easy for black to bring the king to
safety and white
you know gave up a pawn but
we'll have something but no rookie one
knight of six bishop t2
and you know what i remember
years back i was reading
uh and i want to do that once again
because i think those were
very interesting books um the books of
uh victor korchner victor corchinere was
a gracious player who believed that
doesn't matter if the pawn is poisonous
you should still take it
and try to defend and uh maybe that was
uh that was duda's uh approach as well
just um take the pawn and then see
afterwards what you're gonna do next d5
defend it and the bishop keep the e file
closed so that there's no way for white
to somehow sacrifice any six get pieces
into play
and reach your key bishop f3
now this probably was a small mistake
that
von forest did i think in this position
uh white maybe should go
for
bishop g5 or bishop f4 i
don't particularly like the placement of
the bishop in d2
i think that bishop can be improved
somewhere
um also in some situation
black may be considering
to push the central pawn so you want to
make sure you know that's not an option
in some situations black can also play
bishop d6
and give up the g7 pawn and then go rook
g8 right for the attack
so having the bishop you know in g5 or
f4 can certainly be helpful
because um there's not going to be
bishop d6
and if for example you play like i don't
know
like this move for example you can play
c3
you have to be um
careful about that pawn in some
situations of course
bacon castle and then white can play b4
you know the point is that
white will be able to take black special
pair you either take the knight here
or you go bishop e7 which will allow
knight c6 so
it's one or the other
let's play bishop f3 which i think was a
mistake
why was it a mistake because
although it feels that you're actually
opening up the file
you do not have a sacrifice and you did
give up upon and if you don't have a way
to try to get back
this you know this
pawn
it's not going to be very good bishop c5
and now black went from having a bishop
in e4
to having a 1984 which is going to be
much stronger
because now we'll have the opportunity
to make more trades
like as an extra pawn and more trades
are
going to happen the closer we go to the
end game the more chances black has
to win i think because they have an
extra pawn
b4 uh bishop v6
and now um bishop back
of course there was a possibility for
black to take after that
rook c8 queen maybe queen e7
and now in this position uh queen c7
the point is that if you go bishop takes
b4 of course there's knight c6
so you don't really want to allow this
even if you took another pawn white can
probably take here you don't have that
rook g8 and taking g2 anymore
they also can play c3 after that you can
play rook
bringing the rook to to d1 maybe with
potential sacrifices the bishop is going
to be very strong
there's no need for that with black with
black you need to try to find the right
way to bring your king to safety
and you'll see more later queen c7
and white played queen h3
a mistake after which the game goes
downhill
he's trying desperately i think he was
trying to make the sacrifice work knight
takes e6
pawn takes queen takes then some f3
maybe
the skin will be in the center these
were probably
white ideas here but seriously
they didn't seem to work and that's
and and here the reason is
black can make this very simple move and
all voice ideas
of attack are gone and black stays with
an extra pawn
look at this beautiful move
look at this super beautiful move
shortcut
you do not have a sacrifice you do not
have a mate i have an extra pawn
this is hanging as well that seas two
pawn is kind of weak
there's pressure in h2 as well let's not
forget about that
yeah by the way i haven't pointed that
out of course after queen c7 we had
a threat there but um
but maybe because h3 h3 for example
wouldn't work because i think we would
do something similar
uh but maybe maybe in that position
uh white could have played um maybe
white could have played c4
that would be like a small tactical idea
that could have
could have helped white open up a little
bit
more
uh you can never take uh taking h2 just
trying to do this you obviously cannot
take with the pawn if you take
the queen the idea is maybe knight f5
you know trying to take
put some pressure
but i really like the way black
continued this you know
extra pawn simple simple chest trade
bishop c5 i'm willing to make another
trade and take your c2 pawn
rook f1 we're also threatening by the
way this
and getting the pawn so taking any
in d4 and c2 or pushing and taking that
one
and now black took broken8
in order to avoid rook takes a1 and uh
and bishop takes d4
and now look at that bringing in the
piece closer
offering a trade because we have an
extra pawn
and if you're gonna take here
and try to go for the end game
oopsie what did i do
sorry guys i made a mistake
i've made a mistake i apologize
fixing it it got fixed i think
and now um it is game it is basically
game over if
we make this trade now we go e5
there's no way for white to save
themselves but
f3 was played and um
and now the final move of the game rook
to a2
and white resigned i mean
if you take the knight
this will happen and you lose the knight
as well
and um
you don't really have a way like if if
you move the bishop we take here
and basically it is just game over
so the reason i showed this game is
because well first i thought it was an
interesting idea this queen d3 queen g3
was kind of an interesting idea to give
up the pawn
they can see that not in all situations
where you give up the pawn
it is going to be um
game over i mean sometimes the opponent
takes it and you don't have much
if you do sacrifice upon make sure you
find the right way
to keep your initiative and actually
take advantage of your opponent's king
in the center if you don't see that
do not give up material so this is a
novelty but maybe not the best i think
white should keep up with you know these
ideas of
development defile this is weak
and so on and the last game that i chose
to show
for today was this game that was played
between
blue bomb and uh shaqiri alma media
shakurir he's
an amazing chess player it's very hard
to beat
and um i don't know
i like to finish with the game where
someone who's supposedly a little bit
weaker wins
maybe that's why i chose this game but
no also i i really liked it i
it was a chromefeld and uh in gruenfeld
and uh an opening that the mamadara
plays
um you got to lose it so let's see
how that game went d4 knight f6
knight 3 d5 e3
g6 before g7
because you know in the beginning when
you saw the way the game went you could
have asked me what what
what kind of growth no growth fault that
was something completely different
i know but it transposed into a grown
thought
pawn takes and it's kind of nice
actually to play it on this move order
compared to the typical one which would
be like this
if you actually play with knight c3 and
you try to go for this line
you see you have the 19 c3 so now you
have to go for the line
with e4 and takes and then
okay this is a classical very famous
line but you have to go for this but um
the way white played it
you are still getting a groomfeld right
because
black here played bishop seven didn't
play c6
um to try to protect i mean that could
have been a schlecter
he's letting you the opportunity to take
so you are taking now but basically
in in black's uh advantage like
for white the plus is the fact that
there's no knights in c3 so when you
play e4 this knight needs to move
it cannot take here and start attacking
the center
the negative or bad point for white is
that then instead of having the 19 c3
they actually have the pawn here and
when they play e4 which is exactly the
move the white played
white basically lost a move because they
played e3 and e4 in two moves
so the zero is a plus and a minus knight
there
and now h3
the point is that y does not have
sufficient
uh defense on the d4 pawn
so um you're playing h3 in order to
avoid bishop g4 and trying to undermine
the protection of of the pawn castle
knight c3 d5
uh bishop e3 now i personally like this
kind of idea
for white to play d5 um and getting the
space and now okay if you're gonna give
out the bishop there
we're super happy we have potential
attacks that's not gonna happen
so i personally like to to push this
pawn forward even if we're giving the
e5 outpost it will it will not be
something
um super big like if black plays here
we can go maybe bishop f4 not to allow
the knight to come
you know to e5 so d5
but blue bomb decided to go for bishop
e3
and after the capture knight takes of
course
and bishop d7
black has to finish their development
and they certainly want this knight to
go to c6 they cannot bring it
immediately because
we're going to take and mess up his
pawns if he does so
immediately and instead of doing that
bishop d7 to support the knight to go
there very natural
still balanced position white is
finishing their development
knight c6 castle and in this position
there were quite some games played and
black usually would take him
in d4 and then go bishop c6
um and then okay if you trade the
bishops king takes if you go queen b3
you know he can he can go to here
you can go queen d4 put more pressure
bring in the rook on the
on the default pretty equal right the
position is symmetrical the pawns are
symmetrical there's not so much to be
worried about
but black went for rook c8 instead so
mommy the roof is basically coming with
this
novelty um
waiting one more move with
with the trade in d4 uh or at least that
was the idea i believe
but guess what why decided not to trade
anymore
so we still have some symmetrical
position white has a slightly bit
more space due to pawn in e4
and and it it's a little bit easier for
them to keep more pieces on the board
the knights even the knights look the
same
and it may seem like black's doing a
little bit better because this fiance
bishop is
this thing kind of well there but what
he got
what got to happen after knight b395
i think here this would have been
slightly better or more interesting
the idea is that you're taking control
over the c4 square maybe you go knight
c4 maybe you go bishop c4 first then
knight c4
but you have to try to trade a little
bit some pieces because even if it's so
symmetrical
because of the spawning e4 white can
have a slightly better
placement for the queen but black
doesn't quite so they have to get rid of
some pieces to make it easier for
themselves
in my opinion of course 95
and now blue bomb wait for knight c5 i'm
super happy i think this is
for this move i really like this move
because
um it's not so easy for black to chase
away
that pawn is weak the queen will go to
b3 has a place
then the rooks come on central files and
black is struggling to place their queen
somewhere
queen b3 e6
and now because we pretty much have all
our pieces pretty well placed
white probably realized in keys of root
e1 the queen just moves and there's
nothing
so they decided to take advantage of the
badly placed knight in b6
a5 knight went to d7 and it seems like
oh
now black is trading so they will be
doing really well because
of pieces of the board and
what knight b5
a6
queen before so
what are we dealing with once again
seems to have been kind of a i don't
want to say recurring but
the theme of of today i i didn't plan it
exactly that way i just kind of liked
some of the games of course but bishop
there
white has the bishop there and the
position is opened
here and um and he has slightly more
space
this knight doesn't quite have a good
location to be placed on knight e5
should have pro probably been played um
my midair 198 it's probably very similar
i
didn't quite see a big difference makes
in my opinion a little bit more sense to
go a little bit more active
uh this move i don't think it would work
due to
knight f3 check so if you want to bring
this knight somehow
on a slightly better location probably
it should be three five
in my opinion but yeah he played it
through b8
still like kind of similar look at roxy
one
knight c6 queen a3
oopsie okay fc1 i'm sorry
alexi one knight c6
queen a3 we have to keep this pawn
protected
oops that 90 spin
we can try to double maybe we'll have um
we'll have potential captures in a6 pawn
takes and then taking c6 and win upon
this part of the game is very natural
until white gave out that point
you can also go back or you can take the
thunder pawn
it's always tricky which one to take
this could have been a line to be played
but now i think black can take here and
you will get the chance to take your a6
pawn back you have the bishop here but
since the pawns
all stay on the king side there's not so
much
for them to to keep
pressing for a win but now
mommy dino decided to take this one
and this is what happens when you take a
central pawn
and it's with the queen and it gets kind
of stuck
human
where should the screen go what do you
guys think
in my opinion
v8 e7
might will get their pawn back
but
these ones are doubled you got me there
to stay and defend it i may have to play
okay
because if i try to to do something like
this
maybe a4 and you take it later you keep
your double pawns but
those can be very annoying and if you go
rook a8 now there is this check which
actually makes you lose the name
you can go there and
okay bishop hair is gone there's not so
much to do anymore
simple chess
knight d4 was played instead
kind of crazy uh to see that i i thought
it was kind of crazy to see that mom
madera plundered
this easily and this easily okay
i mean i'm i'm a little bit too tough
right now i mean i i really like
his style and everything um
and i think a lot of us are looking for
for these kind of games when you see a
very strong player that you like
um it's not like you i i mean this
sounds strange a little bit the way i
wanted to say it but
you want to try to find um games also
when they mess up too to realize that
nobody's perfect we can all blunder
and um you just need to to understand
where you're plundering and try to avoid
those kind of
mistakes in the future so the queen had
to go back but 94 is the blunder because
black completely forgot probably here
about the queen
nh4 being trapped and after b bishop
here
he resigned because it is clear that
after capturing
queen takes and now if you go queen to
h5
there's g4 which traps the queen there's
nothing you can do to save yourself
so bishop g5 to strike the queen
there were tons of and so many really
really great games
uh this week with the european club cop
taking place and i think some other
tournaments i hope the games i chose
were
uh were interesting to you so once again
so we had savannah against kansuki
which was a game where there was a lot
of focus
on getting a better position more
like i'll just say like more space
really nicely placed pieces
um and then i think it was really nice
to see how wide step-by-step improve the
position even if they lost their
advantage at some point
they kind of gradually improved creating
a weakness on the other side of the
board
getting the outpost in d6 placing a
knight there
and step by step uh
just improving the position
basically then there was this game of
forest where there was an interesting
novelty from whiteside
but unfortunately giving up the pawn
didn't
really help why they actually didn't
really
have a way to get the pawn back and
things were getting kind of
not really helpful uh for them and then
this last game where
it was pretty balanced throughout until
black got their queen stuck in the
center
and um and probably i mean i think mommy
there was probably trying to play for
for for um for a win of course here if
you missed bishop g5 but
he probably in his mind he thought
this knight will be placed really
greatly in the center the king would
have to move the queen
would come back to the eighth and then
okay they can they can take this bishop
in f3 as well
it's after that that's what they wanted
to do
but no that didn't seem to happen so
small blunders
can lead to losses
these were the three games that i had
prepared for today
um i hope
next week there will be even nicer games
i really hope you guys enjoyed it and
had stuff to learn
from from these games i've been having
trouble as you guys
have noticed i have been having trouble
accessing the action the the chat of
this
uh of this video and
i'm gonna maybe try one more time and
see if you guys have any questions
before we finish
i'm not sure because
uh let's see
why am i prone there's a problem in my
chat and i don't know why
ah here okay
finally i was able to get the chat if
you guys have any questions about the
games
i will take a few
oh you guys okay seems seems that
everything was going well no questions i
think i answered
most of those um as i was talking i'll
be more mindful
next time this is day one uh
my day one of gm residency i'm really
looking forward to the entire month of
april
thank you so much for tuning in on san
luis chess clubs
youtube channel be sure to check out
some of the other videos
that the club has made there's lots of
great material to help you improve
don't forget to subscribe if you like
the
videos um and give them
a thumbs up if you like them too so that
we know what
more videos to create
and check out the twitch channel as well
and i will see all of you
very soon alright
goodbye everyone thank you